[Musique]
bonjour il est 7 heures du matin ça a
été au café une nouvelle émission que
nous vous proposons sur france 2 chaque
samedi et chaque dimanche nous passons
trois quarts d'heure ensemble nous
prendrons le petit déjeuner ensemble
s'il veut le voulez bien avec un invité
qui sera à mes côtés ce sera un homme
politique aujourd'hui mais aussi les
autres semaines nous aurons des
écrivains des chanteurs aussi des
artistes qui seront là pour parler
essentiellement de leur curiosité de
leurs loisirs de ce qu'ils font pendant
le week-end on parlera pas du tout
travail ça je vous le promets alors pour
cette première émission j'ai choisi un
homme politique un homme politique très
dangereux je pense que ce n'est
d'ailleurs le plus dangereux de la
classe politique française
il s'agit d'un homme qui utilise une
arme une arme fatale c'est le rire
l'humour
la réplique qui fait mal on ré santini
bonjour bonjour quand vous êtes le
député-maire d'issy-les-moulineaux issy
les moulineaux c'est une une ville qui
se trouve à la périphérie de paris qui
est à comme ça ont franchi la porte de
versailles et là on se retrouve en fait
dans une banlieue à ces polices est
assez riche maintenant à ce que l'on
bourgeoisie comme son machin bâti toi
comme sa mère là c'est vrai que lorsque
j'ai eu un loupé ou le nahd d'enveloppés
n'ont pas commencé jeudi quand nous
avons pour en fait préparer cette
émission alors certains m'ont dit andré
santini mais oui andré santini niang
koné c'est un homme politique mais c'est
le sait le rigolo voilà voilà
et là ça ça vous désole un peu bien sûr
la proche du gouvernement
ouais mais vous l'avez été oui c'est
vrai oui parce que ministre c'est bien
mais ancien ministre dure plus longtemps
c'est ce que vous dites oui mais vous
avez des formules comme ça à
l'emporte-pièce un peu tout fait
préparer ça vous prend beaucoup de temps
histoire la nuit
jamais je dors très bien très bien très
vite c'est la formule ça vous vient
quand les autres ne la trouve pas et
puis parfois on l'a rabote un peu pour
la faire joli quand raymond barre était
à côté de moi il s'endormait parfois et
je me secoue est pour qu' il ne sombre
pas et dans les moments où il était très
actif il avait l'habitude de se tourner
les pouces et j'ai dit tiens il commence
en jogging alors c'est resté après ils
vont n'a pas voulu heureusement alors
pour éviter qu'on s'adore parce qu'au
contraire là il faut qu'on soit aux
knicks et le début du week end je vous
demande évidemment posé une question qui
va être rituel désormais thé ou café le
matin tu as fait c'est du café que vous
prenez plus on est assez classique un
carrousel on dit toujours que les
journalistes sont elles servent ils oui
hein vous vous servez la soupe
exactement regardez c'est beau la suit
mon est-ce que c'est très beau ses
envies c'est important pour vous le
petit déjeuner c'est un rôle non il ya
deux petits déjeuners il ya les vrais ce
qu'on pensait soit alors c'est rapide
c'est emballé on écoute les radios qui
succède pas assez en tête deux sans
doute
et puis il ya les faux petit déjeuner
qui sont maintenant tragiquement à la
botte de 1 nous réunis pour parler
politique pour par les médias
ça dépend ça se passe quand le lieu est
sympathique c'est au moins agréable et
puis d'ordinaire c'est comme les repas
d'affaires ou ou les repas politiques
ont des jeux de mal et on parle encore
plus mal donc j'ai horreur du mélange
des gens le week-end a de l'importance
pour vous c'est un calque réellement
avait dit week-end ça veut dire quoi
week-end bon on peut imaginer qu'on
s'arrête on fait autre chose rare oui
mais non voilà des politiques c'est
pourri ces fainéants qui ne font rien
oui je m'étais mis entre guillemets
ils n'ont pas de week-end il faut le
savoir et c'est tant mieux parce qu'on
travaille tellement pendant le reste de
la semaine que si d'un seul coup on
avait un break
on risquerait l'hémorragie cérébrale là
un week-end comme aujourd'hui premier
week-end de février sa démarche par quoi
par des mariages alors il ya des
mariages oui j'en fais beaucoup quand
les gens le souhaitent et c'est toujours
très sympathique parce que je je me
renseigne un peu je fais un petit
discours sur mesure
et puis on voit tout je peux raconter
une histoire un peu un peu lestes 17
heures du matin au wei assez rapidement
retrouvé je faisais ya quelques temps
des noces d'or dont ils avaient tous les
deux les tourtereaux 83 81 4 ans ils
s'étaient mariés pendant la guerre
une alerte merci pour la génération et
puis alors le monsieur il était très
grand il avait un blouson rouge c'est
bizarre mais les rouges alors on se met
pour la photo puis jeudi à damas côté
elle petit ton noir qui s'habille comme
edith piaf vraiment votre époux il est
formidable avec cette veste tonitruante
miens monsieur le maire il est beau
comme une quête neuf tout le monde
éclate de rire et j'entends le vieux
monsieur qui laisse tomber monsieur le
maire quelle mémoire
alors oui mariage ça peut être aussi
drôle
on ignorait se retrouver dans dix
minutes maintenant on va prendre
connaissance de l'actualité mais bruno
roger-petit suivi d'une météo et ensuite
on vous mettra à l'épreuve
à tout à l'heure
c'est santini pourquoi
si les moulineaux c'est vraiment pour
faire parler encore de votre commune oui
tout comme une envie que l'on parle
son art de vivre son microclimat et
quand j'étais au ministère la
communication j'avais assisté à
l'explosion de de la phase météo du
journal qu'on a commencé par séparer du
journal que l'on a sponsorisé apparaît
que l'on mettait en valeur et j'ai
découvert que le moment météo était le
moment maximum d'audimat
tout le monde regarde la météo il ya
plus de clivages politiques
on est en fin du repas alors peut-être
qu'on l'a mais aussi pour pas rater le
film après ou sensibles votants ah oui
oui mais comme vous avez marre simple et
bien sûr c'est la chaleur et perth
intéressant de se dire pourquoi je ne
suis pas de bonne humeur aujourd'hui
autres alors ça peut être le temps cet
affluent oui je crois aussi à
l'astrologie pas donc je regarde
toujours mon horoscope c'est pas
forcément parce que je me suis engueulé
avec quelqu'un ou parce que je suis
anxieux telle autre chose je m'occupe
des choses importantes c'est-à-dire tout
ce qui me dépasse le temps les astres
après les êtres on va davantage vous
connaître grâce à à bertrand danger
bertrand est bien à travailler beaucoup
sur sur vous sur votre personnage ça lui
a pris à temps a fini tel le parce que
le personnage est très éclectique
cultivons effective n'est ce pas et donc
il va vous brosser un portrait à sa
façon écoutons le alors andré santini
bonjour nous allons voir qu'avec vous un
passé simple que un passé simple peut
succéder à présent étonnant vous êtes né
à paris dans le 14e arrondissement
barèges le 10 octobre 1941 d'octobre
22h10 car comment hergé il
mais ça il était midi mais qu'est ce
qu'un nom balance la malbaie presse et
le 22 ou 23 fois sa voix ressemble bien
balances à oui mais vous avez grandi
entre bécon les bruyères et courbevoie
et sept au gré de vos vacances scolaires
que vous ressourcer en corse terre de
vos racines
alors vos études furent sûrement
brillante en tout cas du mont
sanctionnées par un doctorat de droit
dit aussi durement sanctionnées par un
doctorat de droit un diplôme des hautes
études de sciences politiques est plus
exotique un diplôme de japonais alors
vous êtes un élu connu reconnu puisque
distinguer deux fois pas la marianne
d'or en 89 et 94 cette distinction est
amer ce que le concours est un écrivain
alors on va quelque peu contrasté cette
image de bête à concours en signalant un
très honorable titre de chevalier de la
confrérie des amateurs de fromage de
tête ailleurs oui d'ailleurs il ya
plusieurs genres qu'un relevé
oui et bien entendu sans plonger dans
votre quotidien vous êtes conviés vous
avez un langage très imagé pour le seul
plaisir d'un bon mot vous renseigner les
parents disent ah bon vous pouvez aller
très loin voir trop loin lâche vous
savez être d'une
d'une parfaite mauvaise foi que vous
employez vous restez toujours très
pédagogue et amusant jeu petit restait
toujours bien assortir deuxième parce
que je vais y arriver je dirais même
plus je restais toujours vous restez
toujours très pédagogue la preuve
lorsque vous engueuler quelqu'un d'un
copieux second vous au pédagogue vous
aimez le vin la cuisine rustique ou
sophistiquée non mais je fais pas osé
précisément fin le 20 la cuisine
rustique qu'elle se fasse tickets non
non mais malgré quelques cadres comme
les céréales oui voilà justement j'ai
des infos là ce n'est pas de devenir
encore mais maculaire a encore frappé
pas encore mais on en parle peu et
justement quelques recommandations
médicales ne vous ont cependant pas
comment dire non pas entamer votre
passion pour les rampes malus par ses
pairs tout le monde pour le oui avec des
pommes et pourtant et pourtant oui trahi
je peux pas en parler parce que
justement
enfin bref vous êtes très superstitieux
sensible aux symboles et quotidiennement
vous dévorer tous les horoscopes qui
vous tombent sous la main
alors passons maintenant à ce que vous
n'aimez pas parce que vous détestez vous
détestez la connerie la suffisance
oui la couleur verte le bricolage au
propre comme au figuré la journée risque
est plus étonnant le pastis pas dedans à
cause de l'eau que l'on y ajoute
puisqu'en tant que président de la
chambre syndicale et le syndicat des
eaux pardon du syndicat des eaux
d'ile-de-france mais plus simplement
parce que vous détestez là ni pour un
corse - catastrophe selon trois ça peut
surprendre effective alors ne l'auront
compris vous êtes encore plus vrai que
nature
et si vous le permettez à l'heure où le
soleil se lève
faites nous plaisir l'associant votre
passion pour ce talent pour le japonais
alors epinal et le japonais une petite
épreuve
voilà un livre que nous avons trouvé à
dans une librairie haut la main j'ai
bien su que du très bon peut-être
quelques lunes
prothèse dirons nous aider regardez
cette chose là voilà c'est très très
bizarre n'est-ce pas qu'il soit indiqué
m qu'est ce que ça signifie tout ça je
ne pourrai plus c'est vrai non non je
préfère dire allez rouge et noir de
l'ada sur cette semaine à nos terres
mais pas vous humilie au volant et oui
non mais là je suis appelé je quitte
plus et avec quel dommage c'est un jeu
direct c'est une édition un peu triviale
quand même à ce n'est pas très près
respectées il ya très peu d'idées au
gras mouillé c'est bizarre c'est un
cadeau qu'on souhaitait vous faire vous
n'aurez qu'à des normes ces trois
banques et donc je vais le garder
longtemps quelques hameaux des voix en
japonais qu'est ce que cette religion
d'amour des meilleurs vous êtes sensible
quand même à ce qu est un proche allié
de savais que je collectionne et vous
l'a pas dit les nets ce qui est les
boutons mandarin alors c'est commode à
trouver pis pour voyager et alors quand
j'ai besoin d'un livre je vais
effectivement j'ai joli coup et ils vous
disent ne l'avons pas encore ils n'ont
jamais eu mais repasser ce soir et je ne
sais pas comment ils finissent par avoir
de lully ça ne m'étonne pas de vous
c'est un peu pervers qu'enfin on disait
ensemble et on la parle d'ailleurs d'un
portrait vous l'avez pas abordé mon
grand amateur effectivement de cigares
ça roule c'est andré santini bon en ce
moment il ya une actualité qui était
intéressante on parle évidemment de la
drogue dans le sport alors bon j'avais
tendance à bout de demander si vous avez
déjà fumé bon un joint ci c'est quelque
chose qui qui vous faisait sourire ce
cinéma autour de la drogue du cannabis
dans le sport ou si vous pourrez qu'il
faut prendre ça au sérieux alors ce
qu'il faut savoir dans la drogue c'est
pourquoi les gens s'y adonnent tout ce
qui est répressif ultérieure n'est qu'un
pis-aller
quant à un jeune
viens toxico il est trop tard donc il
vaut mieux ça c'est ma le politique qui
revient investir en amont lui redonner
cet espoir empêcher la dérive
mais quand je vois aujourd'hui c'est
vrai les les jeunes fumer un joint comme
les autres moi je n'ai jamais éprouvé ce
besoin donc je n'ai aucun mérite de
tubes en train de dire je suis
formidable et un cigare le cigare de la
vanne le gros cigare vous fais un peu
plat n'est pas d'illusions il attaque le
cerveau on le sait donc je ne vais pas
critiquer ceux qui ont une autre forme
de d'expression par contre ce que je
critique c'est les ayatollahs c'est tous
ces gens qui nous emmerdent aujourd'hui
qui nous dise comment il ne faut pas
fumer ils ne font pas baiser il ne faut
pas boire ça devient terrible c'est
qu'on est entré dans une phase
d'hygiénisme et moi je lutte contre tous
ces gens qui interfèrent dans la vie
privée ce qui me fait rigoler par
exemple c'est que certains juristes sont
contre le tabac et pour la
dépénalisation de la drogue
il faudrait quand même qu'ils
m'expliquent n'est ce pas parce que je
les rencontre souvent dans les débats
je ne comprends toujours pas au moins je
suis je suis tolérant
je ne vais pas critiquer ceux qui fument
ou ceux qui boivent
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aient raison
que j'ai raison j'essaye de respecter
les autres qui ne pratiquent pas ainsi
sans les sans leur imposer mes goûts qui
peuvent être gênant parce que le s'il ya
pas pire dans un restaurant ou ailleurs
on enfume tout le monde mais je
n'accepte pas tout ce qui interfèrent
par ailleurs je pense que il faut faire
confiance aux citoyens développer son
degré d'information mais ne pas lui
imposer direct d'ailleurs ça ne sert à
rien on le voit bien il n'y a pas de
publicité pour le cigare par exemple
jamais on a vendu autant de signes parce
que le cir permet de fumer mieux en
fumant moins je me suis battu avec 9,1 à
l'assemblée non c'est ridicule avait 20
ceux qui vont mourir te saluent
ça devient ridicule j'ai participé à des
débats un peu partout je reçois à chaque
fois comme aujourd'hui certainement des
lettres de jeu
iguiniz vous êtes pour le tabac tue pas
pour le tableau je suis pour la liberté
et la responsabilité
c'est vrai que le terreau des cigares
satin importuner quand même beaucoup
donc je suis sûr que vous demandez tout
de même motorisation à ceux qui vous
entourent
c'est un minimum de courtoisie pour
entrer dans ce studio nous voici
intolérante un troisième benallou
biennale d'art contemporain ce que vous
vous intéressez un petit peu là mais je
ne suis pas l'avion ça fait chaque année
jusqu'au 18 février cette année
en fait d'art contemporain on y voit pas
beaucoup de sculptures on y voit encore
moins des peintures on y voit des
téléviseurs etc ce qui est un petit peu
agacé les mines mauvaise humeur notre
journaliste du service culture louis 15
regardez plutôt c'est le temps que je
sais ce que vous allez me dire qu'il ya
un peu tôt pour vous montrer les restes
d'un entrepôt de chez darty tomber aux
mains d'une bande de potaches des
beaux-arts ou vous faire découvrir les
nouvelles salles de l'aéroport de roissy
ne venait pas du tout nous sommes à la
biennale la troisième biennale d'art
contemporain de lyon ayant une tendance
qui se dessine pour la sculpture
c'est plutôt pr carré écran plat avec
donc les coins carrés l'écran plat pour
la peinture aussi d'ailleurs pour les du
sein et même qu'on le macramé
au fond je suis injuste il n'y a pas que
des télévisions la biennale pour les
sponsors la troisième biennale d'art
contemporain de lyon ont fait appel à la
fondation électricité de france et à
samsung electronics remarquez on
comprendre car entaché renoncer
contre-visite la biennale télévision une
jolie forme
bien sûr toutes les télévisions peuvent
laisser le visiteur perplexe et ce qui
ne laisse pas d'étonner c'est le coût de
cette 3ème biennale d'art contemporain
de lyon 16 millions de francs ce qui
représente exactement le budget annuel
d'une ville comme lyon pour son action
culturelle
ça fait réfléchir et voici maintenant la
première question de notre concours
ceci est une oeuvre d'art thermiques ou
nucléaires
à brno vite il faut toujours dire les
catalogues
ce catalogue il faut vraiment le lire
car il précise également que la biennale
se situe désormais entre perlimpinpin et
pinocchio
en ce qui me concerne je connais une
petite souris de grandes oreilles qui
peut dormir tranquille dans son château
du val de marne
votre réaction des sentiments très bien
il a tout à fait raison ce genre d'art
entre père n'a peint que pinocchio il a
raison lorsque j'étais aux misères la
communication j'avais inauguré avec
madame mitterrand une exposition de je
ne sais quel artiste brésilien est
annoncé à lyon alors j'en suis encore va
t'en donne versifiée il y avait donc une
sorte de tente on est passé en dessous
il y avait des aspirateurs traîneaux
avec le flexible en laye en érection qui
soufflait et une balle de ping pong
tenait évidemment par ce phénomène
physique il y avait douze aspirateur
d'un côté 12 de l'autre et l'acte
culturel consistait à traverser ce
nouveau grand canyon
elle est écroulé de rire présidente et
moi aussi
heureusement ne faisait pas très claire
est vraiment
l'impression que l'on se moque de nous
ça n'est pas ça la contemporain c'est
vraiment csu c'est de la provocation
bourgeois ça vous de plus on parlait de
téléviseurs effectivement dans cette
exposition il ya énormément de
téléviseurs mais vous vous êtes quand
même un amateur de télévision parce que
vous utilisez le visiophone très
régulièrement
en fait c'est pour le plaisir de vos
envois voir en télévision pour le
plaisir de jouer les cabots comme vous
le faites souvent on s'est vraiment
passé
non non j'utilise beaucoup la
visioconférence et c'est vrai que j'ai
un appareil de visiophonie sur mon
bureau mais il ya tellement peu
d'abonnés qu' il vaut mieux je regarde
mes collaborateurs quand ils le veulent
bien parce qu'il ya quand même un cachet
avec la cie vos collaborateurs qui sont
nos complices
oui contient souvent vous des rides y
ait un petit peu les réunions en imitant
colombo à colombo c'est extraordinaire
ça commence à faire un peu vieillot
maintenant mais mais moi j'aime beaucoup
sa façon au jeudi c'est génial mais
surtout je prends la méthode oui j'ai
compris c'est comme ça qu'on m'a fait
oui on va dépenser 500 mille francs pour
économiser du fuel mais c'est une très
bonne idée
j'en parlerai à ma femme et c'est
vraiment tout ça c'est le bon sens que
l'on bossé pour ça que ça plaît à notre
bon sens qu'on va partager tous les
samedis dans thé ou café c'est celui de
jennifer 4 jennifer bonjour c'est aussi
jour de nuit
jennifer est avec nous pour parler de
livres
elle aura désormais chaque semaine un
coup de coeur pour un bouquin et puis un
petit coup de griffe aussi comme dame
sait bien le faire pour un autre bouquin
est alors cette fois vous avez alors là
j'ai choisi mon coup de coeur de la
semaine c'est le livre de patrick
grainville le lien ou parler aux stay
alors je sais que vous n'aimez pas
d'ores et déjà mais ça sera encore plus
agréable de ces vous convaincre alors
patrick grainville bien sûr est très
connu prix goncourt en 76 pour les
flamboyants le mien très bon livre le
lien et son 14e roman on peut citer
entre autres et non non non on peut
citer entre autres l'orgie la neige
colère les paradis le paradis des orages
mais malgré cette production prolifique
il trouve encore le temps d'enseigner
dans un lycée de banlieue à sa retrouver
je crois et le personnage est assez
fascinant avec sa séduction désinvolte
mais ces livres sont encore plus
fascinant
j'étais mal arthur comme très sensuelle
presque érotique louis très sensuelle et
très chaud car on a tout dit graville on
a eu de son écriture baroque fiévreuse
coloré de sa bombe ans de mots comme
s'ils voulaient s'en fourrer jusque là
mais on a trop insisté sur ce côté
érotique et ses obsessions sensuelle
pour ne pas dire sexuelle parce que ça
masque une vraie une vraie qualité de
d'histoires des histoires des histoires
très construite et une intrigue
passionnante
alors ça va mieux notre gu massy si ça
vous tient en haleine s'en détache pas
comme ça justement le lien je vous
disais que c'était peut-être le lien qui
nous tenait nous lecteurs pris au piège
de ce livre alors pour moi toute façon
ouvrir un livre de graville
c'est vraiment ouvrir la boîte des
sortilèges c'est accepter l'entente
tours de condos accepté l'invitation
mais justement vous qu'être sensible aux
symboles comme on le sait tout à l'heure
c'est rempli de symboles non parce que
le roman se passe dans le xiiie
arrondissement où la communauté chinoise
que tout ce qu'il écrit sur mais les
chinois les entre la cetera le sa
j'adore
alors dès l'instant où il passa ses
fantasmes car c'est du fantasme sexuel
et qui voit une fille elle est allongé
devant lui c'est formidable il à prendre
compte et d'ailleurs je pas comment il
fait il est habituellement donc non non
il a bien mieux fait que ça assez bien
résumé le lis très bien résumée
l'histoire mais je vais redire un petit
peu plus pour essayer de convaincre les
téléspectateurs
tout commence en fait par une rencontre
accident de voiture m
le personnage principal renverse une
femme dans la rue et là tu sous les yeux
de sa fille m'a à une chinoise une jeune
chinoise au sang noir qui pousse un sens
un cri un cri énorme un crime monstrueux
est hanté par ce cri et pour se racheter
m va tenter va décider de faire d'elle
une star de la chanson et à y parvenir
voila voila il va essayer de mettre en
scène ce cri à celle de l'amour devant
le bouddha ça m'a beaucoup amusé ça
c'est formidable
bon c'est le syncrétisme absolue le
syncrétisme il ya un messianisme c'est
moi je trouve ça extraordinaire et je
sais pas ce que j'aime l'extrême orient
que j'étais à peu près jusqu'au bout et
mais bon autant que ce solide comme je
disais tout à l'heure créer une sorte de
livre de pierre et il ya une référence
très précise à victor hugo sans se
situera cela quand il écrit sur la
pierre
est bon et la femme jennifer je crois
très bien c'est le personnage qui nous
manquait mais la force de gravité qui
joue sur les figures du mythe et qu'il
réactualise alors notamment dans le
concert le concert géant où c'est une
sorte de messe comme sa grand messe un
peu sacrilège en fin et tout ça sur fond
de show business ou sous fond de
show-business justement c'est ce mythe
le mythe dans la modernité alors on se
rend compte que même les mythes les plus
archaïques les rites les plus archaïques
pardon les plus payen trouve un sens
dans l'époque dans notre époque alors
graville comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure nous en effet avec les la
culture les mythologies païenne
chrétiennes bouddhistes dans une sorte
de bric-à-brac incroyablement maîtriser
réussi ce qui est tout à fait inverse
à mon sens du livre de gens dorment sous
la série green set il a eu presque rien
sur presque tout réussi rôle inverse il
est venu chez moi tu restes conférence
il
il est formidable il est éblouissant
c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement doux et
éblouissant en effet alors justement
j'étais déçu parce que moi qui adore
jean d'ormesson
là j'ai trouvé que c'était un peu une
sorte de bric-à-brac jeu les filles
comme vous qui déçus par jean d'ormesson
je suis quand même un conditionnel mais
malgré tout je dois dire que là je m'en
suis jamais posé sur les lèvres presque
rien plus que presque tout bon
savez-vous jennifer qu'on aurait senti
aussi l'auteur d'un best seller le
régime fiscal des sociétés étrangères en
droit comparé on doit pouvoir faire
quelques-uns c'était simplement savourer
travail comme d'écrire un roman ou un
essai ou un document non le dernier j'ai
sorti c'était mieux vaut en rire je
voulais appeler ça le chauve souris et
puis l'éditeur a préféré un autre titre
oui c'était des vacheries ça un collier
de perles
j'avais un livre presque sérieux c'est
mon opinion et je la partage sap a été
perçu comme on croyait rire en achetant
alors c'est un peu dommage je fais
vraiment de plus en plus le bouffon
point de l'image c'est ça la table je le
droit de dire des choses sérieuses en
temps là j'ai peut-être faire quelque
chose sur le politiquement correct cela
on est complètement dépassé déjà non bon
ça va l'être quand j'aurai terminé ce
soir des bosses ce sera un bide
j'organise le naufrage vous parliez tout
à l'heure de d'issy les moulineaux donc
votre commune on évoque en ce moment
dans l'actualité la violence dans les
collèges et les lycées
j'imagine que c'est un souci lorsque
l'on est maire comment vous y veiller
que vous est ce que vous prenez des
précautions et des mesures contre cela
alors les collèges et lycées ne relève
pas de la compétence des maires donc
inauguré récemment un collège avec le
président pasqua et j'ai tous les
proviseurs et principaux des collèges
nissan tour était présent et j'ai noté
depuis quelques temps des conseils de
discipline extrêmement ferme avec des
exclusions ce qui ne s'était pas produit
depuis un certain temps je crois que là
encore il faut se mettre d'accord avec
avec les enseignants avec les élèves sur
les objectifs que l'on veut atteindre et
puis ensuite il faut faire respecter la
loi
parce qu'il ya des gens qui aujourd'hui
ont perdu les repères où il dérive on de
ces prisons sont une respecte personne
ce n'est pas normal qu'un gamin de 13
ans 14 ans insultes
un enseignant ce n'est pas normal il y a
quelque chose qui n'a pas fonctionné un
moment
dans les maires doivent apporter un
climat de sécurité et mr romeyer les
mères msi on dit souvent qu'ils n'ont
pas de pair et pas de repères bon eh
bien il faut que les maires
interviennent donc nous moi j'appuie
d'abord les enseignants je leur dis mais
nous sommes avec vous dans l'oeuvre de
fermeté à condition que les règles
étaient bien poser avant et puis je
provoque des parents et je le redis ce
n'est pas normal je vais vous parler
quelque chose qui ne me concerne pas
mais qui vous concerne vous et qui
concerne l'avenir de vos enfants il faut
reprendre les affaires en main si vous
vous démission des parents
il sait pas une démission c'est souvent
une submersion qu'on l'ait c'est là que
nous intervenons si le père est au
chômage
quelle autorité voulez vous qu'il est à
la maison on c'est pour ça qu'il faut à
tout prix relancer la machine que les
gens retrouvent la dignité du travail
un père chômeurs de longue durée si les
maghrébins en particulier n'a plus
d'autorité sur sa famille alors après
tout le monde part en petite délinquance
en petit trafic de drogue
et c'est là que nous devons nous sentir
concernés
on ne peut pas démissionner nous non
plus les mères restent aujourd'hui
souvent les derniers pivot les derniers
raccommodeur du tissu social il faut le
savoir est d'ailleurs dans les mesures
prises récemment parus le premier
ministre jean-claude gaudin hériteront
tong à revaloriser le rôle des mères on
accomplit ses pas en envoyant des
préfets comme les dragons dans les
campagnes ou schwahn que l'on peut faire
avancer les choses il faut au contraire
des gens qui soient encore considérée et
qui soit crédible et très présent dans
la bêtise ça c'est lui qui ce qui mène
des actions transversales
tout se tient au cours de cette émission
va prendre l'habitude d'aller à à
l'étranger on va voir comment ceux qui
vivent ailleurs que chez nous parce le
week-end
c'est assez important effectivement de
s'ouvrir un peu sur le monde et
aujourd'hui on va aller à pékin
tout l'hiver par des températures très
basses et des chinois qui sont pas très
jeune n'est pas tout jeune vous allez
voir sur ces images qui chaque jour se
baigne
lattes pour s'activer il se baigne aussi
de vous allez voir dans une eau
excessivement glacé un reportage de
jérôme boeny les chinois n'ont droit à
leurs deux jours de week end que depuis
tout juste un an
l'hiver il se laisse glisser sur les
lacs gelés des parcs
certains pékinois pousse même le vice
jusqu'à passer sous le niveau de la
glace
tiens donc
ils sont trois mille six cents membres
dans le club des nageurs divers de pékin
chaque après midi ils se font chuter la
température
saut en hauteur alors comment lots
monsieur wang froide très froide au
début c'est vraiment très froid à cannes
mais après 20 secondes on se sent mieux
[Musique]
et
ok mais le japon vous connaissez aussi
la chine alors la chine très peu c'est
une de mes grandes lacunes
bien sûr je connais la région de canton
macao à partir de hong kong et j'ai
failli partir des dizaines de fois
d'autant que le consulat de chine est
sûrement comme il dissimulé nommé je
vais sans doute dirigé une délégation de
chefs d'entreprises d'ici moulineaux
pour des relations d'affaires sur la
chine alors je vais y aller parce qu'il
faut y aller assez longtemps ça ne vaut
pas la peine d'y aller pour quelques
jours vous êtes également par les
cigares présidente de l'association de
l'amitié un franco cubaine
mais est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu
gênant lorsque l'on est secrétaire
général du parti social-démocrate deux
jours démocrate la force démocrate
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que vous faites
vos assemblées générales dans une cape
noire avec force démocrate de françois
bayrou non il faut des grandes théories
le premier avant oui avant c'était un
métier combien cette députée c'est sa
nature
pas ridicule aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
vous êtes devenu un mouvement se
montrent donc bon c'est vrai que donc la
chine vous connaissez moins bien manger
disent adhérer tous force démocrate oui
en cinq grandes formations
oui le japon mais pourquoi là alors on
l'évoqué tout à l'heure au cours de ce
portrait pourquoi vous avez été attiré
dans les années 50 par le japon que vous
avez fait lang zoé ne me donnais 58
quand même là c'est effectivement une
très bonne question et je n'y ai jamais
répondu précisément parce qu'à l'époque
on savait même pas ce qu'était le japon
ou encore aux petites fleurs sur les
aspir'acteurs ou montres molles enfin
n'importe quoi et les kopin's et un jour
j'avais été chercher un collègue un
collègue japonais qui était professeur
inversée tokyo et qui était spécialisée
napoléon le président m'a dit il faut
que tu ailles je cherchais un acte loi
qui puisse correspond à napoléon et
japon et dans la voiture je lui dis
mon cher collègue m'a dit mais je vous
connais je sais qui vous êtes parce
qu'on n'est pas très nombreux il ya
gollnisch par exemple de lyon qui lui
enseigne japonais maintenant et il me
dit je vous connais un petit peu et vous
allez me demander quoi pourquoi je suis
spécialisé la pole et ont dit oui parce
que napoléon ma connaissance a été très
peu au japon enfin je ne garde pas
contre la 3ème ou 4ème commission il
n'ya été
il m'a dit je vais vous poser une
question pourquoi vous avez vous appris
le japonais
donc on me dit sommes revenus il m'a dit
simplement vous avez appris le japonais
parce que vous êtes profondément
insulaires et c'est vrai que j'aime
toutes les îles et nous avons origines
corps oui oui sans doute
et quelqu'un qui n'est dans une île on
sait d'où il est et le japon ou matelly
nous aimons beaucoup
napoléon parce que c'est l'homme qui est
parti d'une île qui a conquis le
continent et il a voit ainsi en termes
freudien que le rêve japonais qui a
toujours était déguisé et on voit ce
qu'est péter de s'étendre alors voyez je
m'en suis resté là cette explication qui
n'en est pas une
on termine les missions avec une
sujétion notre invité nous apportera une
suggestion pour le week-end puisque nous
parle du monde il je pense que vous
allez nous parler d'une balade dans milk
est proche j'habite dans une interview
je suis revenue là donc effectivement
cette île saint germain
et très belle maintenant il y à 20 ha de
deux parcs la deuxième partie va être
transformé en jardin prévu ce sera un
peu giverny avec money des des jardins
impressionnistes avec une flore de nos
régions des déserts bas oiseaux et
autres et il ya la tour aux figures du
buffet il ya un grand poney club avec
des poneys tous alezan est très joli et
puis un peu plus loin il ya la maison de
la nature de dents dans boulogne qui va
venir d'ailleurs dans l'île à nouveau
donc c'est essayer ou près de paris sept
minutes de paris c'est la première vraie
il en sortant de paris et il y à des
milliers de gens qui vont s'y promener
on peut pique-niquer et je crois que
c'est le moment de voir la nature en
hiver tu m'adresse à vous et à votre
tour donc si vous pouvez nous signaler
des activités des suggestions pour le
week-end tous les samedis tous les
dimanches on n'en fera pas ici dans
cette émission était au café
il suffit pour sa bad appeler le 36 68
71 23
vous nous laissez un message le message
sera diffusé donc sur notre antenne
chaque week-end le samedi le dimanche
dès l'instant bien sûr c'est une
activité un petit peu insolite quelque
chose d'un petit peu bizarre qu'on voit
pas partout ça peut être une fois ça
peut être une fête ça peut être une
manifestation commune a énormément
d'ailleurs tous les week-ends en france
donc c'est à numéros utiles 36 68 71 23
on va se quitter j'étais un petit peu
malheureux je vais vous apporter quelque
chose qui va peut-être vous aider à
passer un très bon week end tournebride
connais pas beaucoup
alors on vous a offert quelque chose
regardez ses rivaux ses premières âge je
pense que grâce à ça vous allez pouvoir
passer un week-end formidable venus
construire des petites maisons
il y aura pas de n'avoir pas d'aplomb il
y aura pas deux d'habitation au cabaret
vous êtes à bâtisseurs on sait très bien
quand on veut que vous pourrez coller
voit la télé à la mer regardez-moi star
c'est faux pas est nul on regarde et
pendre et surtout merci marc catherine
de petits bricoleurs de service des
lieux tampon du cndd y voilà
non non et que vous savez pas faire
grand chose de vos dix doigts oui rien
moi je me reconnais voilà merci à vous
merci on se retrouve bien sûr dès demain
demain pour pierre perret pierre perret
qui sera à mes côtés également on
parlera en particulier aussi deux chiens
truffiers sentir très très bon dans ce
studio de thé ou café c'est tous les
samedis tous les dimanches matin à 7h
sur france 2 bonne journée à demain
[Musique]